mais d'abord tenir tenir jusqu'à la
réouverture les professionnels du
tourisme scruteront avec intérêt
vendredi le calendrier de sortie de
confinement du président de la
république avec ses onze mille emplois
le secteur pèse lourd en indre et loire
les collectivités locales le savent bien
depuis le début de la crise d'ailleurs
elles n'hésitent plus à sortir le
chéquier pour aider les sites exemple au
château de gizeh avec paul boyer 1875
euros c'est la somme reçue par les
propriétaires du château de gizeh pour
garder la tête hors de l'eau
une somme représentant l'achat de
tickets d'entrée de ce site touristique
de quoi ré activer la trésorerie en
berne
nous agissons ils ont acheté 250 billets
qui vont être après offert je crois en
priorité aux tourangeaux mais aussi par
des jeux sur internet ou des choses
comme ça pour faire connaître ou
redécouvrir le patrimoine de notre
département
quinze mille billets pour inciter les
locaux à découvrir un patrimoine situé à
deux pas de chez eux
un investissement qui concerne plus de
30 lieux avec plus de 11 mille salariés
dans la filière touristique le
département mis sur une saison digne de
ce nom
l'enjeu est majeur pour l'économie
locale le département des blocs 1
million 400 mille euros en soutien aux
opérateurs d'indre et loire
l'année dernière ils ont fait un
résultat meilleur que ce qui était
redouté
et bien cette année on espère pouvoir à
nouveau bien repartir et c'est le rôle
du département de avec le million 3 dead
de pouvoir les aider rapidement et
simplement
cent vingt mille euros sont investis
pour promouvoir la destination de la
touraine notamment en région parisienne
pour l'heure il continue de préparer
leurs activités estivales afin de
proposer le meilleur accueil possible
aux futurs visiteurs